we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
very specific question about retail
stores why are retail stores doing so
poorly if the economy is supposedly
doing so well
hi David I've got a question for you you
may or may not know the answer I'm just
wondering you see economy is doing so
good it's what you're reported in the
Eastern media in a lot of places they
all say unemployment down and Plumbing's
good the economy is growing doing great
what are some any change doors of filing
for bankruptcy and closing down in 2019
Google change doors closing 2019 and see
what comes up kind of really
mind-boggling that the economy is doing
great everyone is doing fine but there's
banker season doors closing
yeah so listen it's a very good question
which is retail has been such an
important sector in the American economy
for decades how is it that the economy
can supposedly be doing so well if so
many retail stores are closing and the
answer is that the economy is shifting
away from retail now I don't want so let
me issue two very specific disclaimers
one you can still debate whether the
economy is or isn't doing well and you
can argue which indicators we should be
looking at but what cannot be denied is
that the economy in and of itself has
been moving away from retail for a long
time and that there is going to be at a
certain point in time retail is simply
not going to be as important a vertical
and Industry to the economy as it once
was now it still is very important and
when we look at the number of retail
stores closing down due to competition
from online marketplaces Amazon being
one but there are many many others and a
lot of these other closings there is no
doubt that this is a negative force on
the economy the question is is it
outweighed by job creation elsewhere and
the question is well where exactly are
we talking about but the move away from
retail has been happening for a long
time you know it started I used to work
for Circuit City when I was in high
school in college and when BestBuy came
in and paid everybody low hourly wages
instead of commission like we were paid
at Circuit City it was clear that it was
it was the direction of retail no more
sort of better trained and more highly
compensated people at Circuit City the
idea was people making what at the time
I think was eight bucks an hour to just
clerk out computers and offer service
plans and whatnot and that was the
beginning of the end for Circuit City
which ultimately folded and this is just
the way retail is going so we can
evaluate how the economy is doing we can
also understand that retail is just a
not a dying sector but a sector that is
being reformed and reshaped and and far
less prominent than it was once was
we've got a great bonus show we will
talk about a whole bunch of different
stuff including 42% of Americans being
at risk of retiring broke get the bonus
show get the a commercial free audio and
video stream by becoming a member or
patron information about both on our
website